- I assume that it's gonna taste like
a lot of bad choices.
- Someone said it tastes like a hug.
(squeaking)
- [Man] I was sort of hoping
like an alcoholic cow poll.
- [Woman] It says "red
wine-based aperitif".
(sighs)
(laughs)
- The name "tonic wine" does not imply
health giving (laughs)
or medical properties.
- Made by monks.
Okay.
- High caffeine content, 37.5
milligrams per hundred mil.
- I'll be like hyper and drunk.
- This has three cans of Red Bull in that.
(clinking glasses)
- To the monks.
(laughs)
(coughs)
- Ugh, that's horrible.
That smells horrible.
- Whenever I don't like anything,
this eye starts twitching.
I'm like (laughs)
- [Man with glasses]
Wow. That is interesting.
- It tastes like old Jägermeister.
- [inaudible] medicine.
- It tastes like wine,
and then it burns.
- It tastes good enough for
me to carry on drinking it.
- You know that film
"Limitless" with Bradley Cooper?
Where he can then access
100% of his brain?
That's what I feel like.
- I think I'm starting to like it more.
- Don't drink this if you want to sleep
for the next week,
is the advice I would give.
- I mean, 15%, that could
get you pretty drunk.
- This gets you shitfaced quickly,
and it kind of tastes okay.
- Yeah.
- That's going down a treat, though.
- You think?
- Yeah.
- Probably because you're already drunk?
(upbeat music)
- Ughhh.
(laughs)
- [Man with glasses] Ughhh.
- [Woman with glasses]
I am not doing that.